I am such a huge fan I can't begin to
tell you
Thank You likewise for nominations yeah
yeah I mean I'm saying so exciting to be
here your dress you look like a dream
thank you I just can't move in certain
ways because the girls won't want to
come to the party
well maybe late maybe later yeah he's
that ly good at giving their own their
own my out isn't your first choice this
dress it it was the moment I saw it yeah
yeah my god yeah tell the world to find
her and then she was there which is
amazing I've always wanted to go poofy
never had the guts but I'm after for
nominations Ruby it went very well
we were just leaning into your hole shot
we were just want to be in your aura
you don't like your how are you doing
hot everywhere you don't know that 100
oh me too I'm speaking to you a lot
we're all Schmidt's in here today
all right you see anyone here you're
excited to be oh my god I mean so many I
mean all the Game of Thrones people just
all of them I'm a game of Thrones go
hate oh my god me too such a nut for it
I love it
[Music]